I think that generally there is a
problem with with being out there all
the time we we also need our bits off
solitude some people you know the
introverts needed more than others the
the extroverts but we all need it and
and it's important to have a private
life by externalizing everything that we
do and we think about and I think we're
hurting some of our potential for for
growth we learn grow we develop when
when we're reflecting reflecting and
when we are reflecting without thinking
about how this is going to look on on
Facebook or Twitter or on our blog so I
think there is place for for privacy
which we are to some extent losing
having said that the results so much
benefit with with being with the social
networks with being more in touch with
other people you know meeting someone
you went to school with in third grade
thanks to Facebook that's a wonderful
thing
what many people think is that the
problem lies with having too high
expectations so if we lower our
expectations we will not be disappointed
hence we'll be happier the problem
though as a lot of research suggests is
not with high expectations versus low
expectations the issue is wrong
expectations versus right expectations
many people have the expectation that
getting that next raise or buying that
bigger car or getting the the promotion
will will make them happier where in
fact it does need to more happiness but
only for the short-term only there's
only a spike in one space level of
well-being so people who have these
expectations that the achievement that
the external will make them happier will
inevitably be disappointed unhappy the
issue is having the right expectations
if our expectations are that more time
with our family and friends being more
physically active being more grateful
for what we do and what we have if our
expectations are that these things will
make us happier then we have the right
expectations and we will in fact become